-Hi, bud!
-Hi, how are you?
-It's so good to see you.
I'm fantastic.
-I know,
and there are people here.
-Yes! I mean, look at this!
-It's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Doesn't that sound great?
-Friday night. Whoo!
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Last time you were here
was right before "Star Wars"
came out.
-"Star Wars."
-And you were not allowed to
really tell me that you were --
-Anything! The secrets.
-Yeah.
-You could barely tell me
that you were in "Star Wars."
-[ Laughs ] I know.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was nuts.
-That must be so hard. I mean --
-It was. It was all secret,
but it was so cool.
-Did you tell your family?
Did you tell your --
-I did tell them
that I was in it, yeah.
-Were they excited? Impressed?
-Um...no.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know, like --
So, my oldest kid is now 14,
almost 15.
But then, I bet --
I guess he was about 12.
-12, yeah.
-And I said, you know,
"River, I'm --
you know, I'm in 'Star Wars,'
and I really want to, like --
you to come see it with me."
And I think
what he texted back was,
"Why would I want to see it
with you?"
[ Audience aws ]
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I was like,
"Wow! Whoa! Whoa!"
-Yes. Yeah.
-And I think what he meant was,
"I want to see it with my
friends -- like, you're a mom."
-"Yeah, I don't go to 'Star' --
I'm already gonna go see it
with my friends, but..."
-Yeah.
And we did eventually get to --
We got a huge group together.
We all saw it together.
And they all cheered when I --
It was great.
It was super cool.
-See, that's a moment
that I think
that I'm very lucky
to be able to experience.
If you go see a movie that's --
with someone
that's in the movie?
-Yeah.
-I mean...
-I know.
-Dude, it's almost --
It's, like, emotional.
-It is. You're like...
-'Cause you're like --
[ Both shouting ]
-Yeah, I know. "Whoo!"
-And you're --
Oh, and you're screaming,
and everyone's like
"Why are they screaming?"
Like, it's just so much --
But it's a good moment.
-It is super fun.
Yeah, it's really fun.
-Yeah, and it's Mom, come on.
-It's Mom. I know.
-Yeah.
-But I -- It doesn't bug me.
Like, I think that's cool that,
no matter what you do,
you're still an annoying mom
to them.
[ Laughter ]
-No, never.
-They're like,
"Ohh, you're not that cool."
-No, no.
We decorated our set
for Halloween.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
-Well, these have been here.
These are -- Not these,
but everything else...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-...is Halloween decorated.
-Well, I really like
the misty nightscape.
-Yeah. That's new.
That's a new addition.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
Misty nightscape's a new --
-Misty nightscape.
I like a lot.
-You do like it?
-Ooh, I like it.
-Are you --
Do you dress up for Halloween?
Or...
-I grew up with a mom who --
like, she loves Halloween
more than Christmas.
-Wow.
-She's like, very witchy,
and, like, sends me, you know,
like, "Happy full moon."
You know, like...
-Yeah, I love that.
-..."Happy Autumn Equinox."
-Yes, yes.
[ Laughs ]
Exactly, I love that.
-So, Halloween was a big deal.
Yeah, the kids will totally
dress up.
My 5-year-old
is being Darth Vader.
-[ Gasps ] What?
-Yeah.
And with a -- he has this
really cool, like, little thing
that he pushes, and it says,
like, "Luke, I am your father."
[ Laughter ]
And then the
14-year-old is, like,
you know, too cool already.
He's, like, skateboarding
with his friends.
He's like "I don't
trick-or-treat."
-Yeah. I -- when I grew up,
my -- when we --
first off, my kids
are now 6 and 8.
But when they're first born,
you can make them
whatever you want.
-It's the best. It's the best!
[ Laughter ]
And they're like...
-That's the greatest.
-It's the best.
They can do whatev--
Yes. Yes.
-So my -- my --
Winnie was...
-Winnie.
-...they were both
ramen noodle soup once.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so good.
-And I loved that costume.
I said -- And it was just --
My wife glued yarn to it...
-Oh, my God.
-...to a little baby onesie.
-It's so good.
-And we put felt fried egg,
boiled egg in their hair
and scallions.
And we're like,
"Yeah, you're a bowl of ramen."
-That is...so good.
[ Laughter ]
-They would never do that now.
Now they're -- Yeah.
-You can't get them
to do anything.
-No, no.
-No, it's the worst.
-And -- But they are kind --
they're getting into
kind of scary --
they love being scared now.
-Do they?
-Yeah. They enjoy it.
So that's why -- But I mean,
maybe not for "Antlers," but...
-I'd say probably not "Antlers"
for 6-year-olds.
-But by the way, I will say
your movie "Antlers,"
that we're gonna talk about...
-Yeah.
-...not only is it --
of course it's scary and it's --
but it's beautiful.
-It's really -- It is.
It's kind of one of my favorite
things about the movie.
It's very haunt--
Well, Scott Cooper directed it.
I was such a big fan
of his work. He did --
I loved "Crazy Heart"...
-Oh, okay.
-...and a lot of other movies
he did.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-So, when I heard
that he was making, like,
his version of a scary movie,
it's sort of, like,
hauntingly beautiful.
It's a very kind of elegant
scary movie.
-Yeah.
-And then it has
Guillermo del Toro creating,
like,
the master
of all the, like, monsters.
-No, no, I can't even -- No.
-It's so --
-I almost don't ever want
to meet Guillermo del Toro.
-He is -- Oh, my God.
You have to meet him.
-It's --
-He's amazing and so --
-He's 10 levels
above everyone else but...
-He's so alive and interested
and curious about everything.
He's like one of those people --
you know, like J.J. Abrams.
They're just so...
-Yeah.
-They're, like, using more of
their brain than the rest of us.
-Than everyone else.
-Yeah.
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we -- I want to set up
the movie for everyone.
-Okay.
-How -- How do we do it?
-Okay. So, it's a --
it's a horror movie.
Kind of a spooky, moody,
horror movie, set in Oregon.
I'm a teacher,
and I get obsessed
with this student of mine
who is harboring a secret.
And then, in trying to save him,
I sort of try to save myself.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-I want to show a clip
from the movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's Keri Russell
in the new movie "Antlers."
Take a look at this!
-Lucas, did they tell you
at the hospital?
-Tell me what?
♪♪
-Your dad died.
-He's not dead.
♪♪
-Yeah, he is, Lucas.
My brother Paul --
he found him in your house.
♪♪
-No.
That was my old dad.
The one who was sick and mean.
♪♪
My new dad is with Aiden.
But Aiden doesn't understand.
And he needs me.
I just have to feed him,
and he'll love me.
♪♪
-What?
-What?! That --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, that kid. Come on.
-Creep City.
-That -- Come on!
-Creep City!
-Creep City. I love it.
Keri Russell, everybody!
"Antlers" is in theaters today!
[ Cheers and applause ]